it is wednesday 6 41
time for warren cup of joe and metro
sheriff joe lombardo is joining us live
today from metro headquarters good
morning sheriff it's good to see you
alex good to see you we want to start
with this today sheriff the murder trial
of former minneapolis police officer
derek shovin
in the death of george floyd it started
last week so when that verdict does come
down no matter what happens
there is a strong chance for
demonstrations nationwide
is metro preparing for protests here
locally
yeah i would say that we are i mean
fingers crossed like everybody else
um but i think the important piece on
this is
to be proactive and i believe we have at
metro been proactive in this and and
that's
communication with the community
excuse me i think it's very important to
talk about this right not
keep our fingers crossed and hope it
doesn't happen i i
in traditional police work we prepare
for
the inevitable and you know we uh we
over
commit and then hopefully you can just
de-escalate
if it doesn't turn out the way is is
expected
in this case there could be a plethora
of happenings or decisions you know
acquittal an indictment
dismissal you know even if there is an
indictment
people may not be happy with the level
of indictment so that's the important
thing to consider
so what we've done here at metro we
proactively met with the community
uh on several occasions prior to today
and we hope for the best moving forward
and what i mean by hope for the best we
hope for the best that
the community is uh holding hands and
they're together and they're talking
about it versus
uh causing destruction as a result of it
we have pretty good history here in
community interaction and community
engagement
and if you saw last week we did the
metro multicultural advisory committee
press conference and that was a press
conference
orchestrated by them not me not the
government per se
and reaching out to the community and
say hey have patience
we've had success here in the past with
controversial issues
because we've had that patient and we
relied on metro's response
right now sheriff state lawmakers are
considering several bills
that would make it more difficult for
police to use deadly force
including when dispersing protests what
are your thoughts on that
well i think it's it's something that
has constantly be looked at
um you know referenced the on the heels
of
george floyd in the incident there in
milwaukee or minneapolis the uh
we constantly have to talk about it and
here's the reason why
the use of deadly force is a very big
issue it's a very important issue and
it's important that the police
departments
explore the sanctity of life associated
with the use of deadly force
and and and what i'm proud of
here at lbmpd is we've been very
proactive in that space
and it isn't because you know we're the
best of the best i even though i agree
with that
and i would say that but it's because we
had warts
upon us in the past and we realized what
was
occurring in the deadly force base and
then we had to do something about it so
we've been very proactive in placing
policies and
training and procedures in place to um
make sure that we're utilizing deadly
force appropriately
and not just because we can um and
i think we're progressive in that space
and so if you look at the legislature
back to your original question
they're addressing those issues but
those issues
are more in line with law enforcement
statewide versus lb and pd a lot of the
bills have been adopted adapted
and modified to match our policy here at
lbmpd
to make it a statewide function versus
an individual function
and you know and then the important
piece is the duty to render aid the duty
to intervene
those are the key components associated
with
george floyd's incident and those of uh
issues that we've addressed previously
yeah and it certainly has become a
larger conversation since
george floyd's death last year and it
should be so
our last question here today sheriff
we've talked about a spike in car thefts
and break-ins the past few months
do you know what's behind this increase
does metro see a trend there
uh well that's that's a great question
and to answer your question
uh no and but we could surmise in a
couple of different ways um yes there
has been a significant increase 25
percent
across the board in vehicle thefts uh
lower a lot lower than that in actual uh
auto burglaries around two percent
increase so when i say 25 percent that's
a big number because
on an annual basis we average around 7
000 uh vehicle thefts a year
uh so if you put that in and you know
the the math associated with that that's
a big deal
and uh so we're addressing it we're
looking at it and i think part of it is
because people are out and about more
vehicles are being utilized more
a reference post covered and this
new phenomenon that's going on with
catalytic converters and they're in the
rare
earths that's are located in those
converters uh
and how much they cost now per pound in
years past
so there's a you know they may be
stealing the car to
eventually obtain the catalytic
converter versus crawling under it and
stealing it
at the location where it's parked so we
haven't been able to put our finger on
it yet but we're paying attention
and i think the important piece on this
is to educate the public make them aware
this is occurring
and be more vigilant associated with
target hardening
uh their individual vehicles i mean just
this morning on my way here
i pull in the convenience store to get a
cup of joe
and and there was an individual in the
store left their car running out in
front of the store
you know so they could run and run out
but that's what people look for
that's they sit in parking lots and pay
attention to that
or if you leave your keys in your car in
front of your house or in your garage
those are the kind of things that you
need to be aware of to make it harder
and more difficult for a crook to do
what they do yes and don't leave the car
running
all right sheriff lombardo it's great to
see you thank you so much sir have a
great morning
good morning thank you alex all right if
you have a question for sheriff jill and
barter you can send it to us on our
website 8newsnow.com
morning cup of joe is every wednesday
right here on good day las vegas